la loire s'éveille sauvage impétueuse
autour du pont canal et même sur le pont
canal
l'activité a repris une nouvelle
génération de commerçants a choisi ce
carrefour d'eau pour travailler sur la
terrasse de la chocolaterie carole une
bretonne à quitter l'eau salée de son
océan natale pour l'eau douce de briare
est quand même bien s'y voir les bateaux
passer c'est vraiment ils prennent en
photo tout de suite c'est vraiment le
lieu où ils se trouvent mais après c'est
vrai qu'on est un peu décalée du monde
en fait parce que c'est c'est calme
c'est paisible c'est même nous y
travaillons la pression d'être quand
même en vacances tout le temps en fait
sur le pont canal de briare etc 662
mètres de long on annonce bertrand
lemarignier de loire il connaît
l'histoire du monument par coeur c'est
un travail de malade c'est 1,5 million
de river ou taper à la main c'est des
essais petit à petit quand c'est fini on
rempile au petit à petit on fait des
tests pour voir si ça résiste
c'est une oeuvre architecturale et
technologique énorme à l'époque
ce matin là tout plein de touristes
empruntent une dernière fois le pont
avant de rejoindre la loire pour l'été
petite escale à la boutique d'une autre
nouvelle arrivée pascal
ironie de l'histoire le vinaigre
d'orléans les faïences de gien les
biscuits de chambord sont arrivés par
camion ils repartiront bateaux
traditionnels
sam hamad et après le canal latéral
dgo cc charnière bria centre du monde
à la base des canal où ces onze prise en
main du bateau sans permis avec bruno
vous êtes 4 vous pouvez faire charmoy
séparer c'est superbe
vous pouvez vous disputez pendant les
vacances c'est formidable à notre place
d'autres plaisanciers s'apprête déjà à
prendre le canal dans l'autre sens on
croise une fois on croise deux fois et
ensuite on vient le mettre à l'envers
ça s'appelle le noeud de tak et quand on
est sur le canal qu'on croise des
pêcheurs ont qu'on croise des péniches
habitable est généralement habitées on
va ralentir pour réduire la vague
d'étrave à l'arrière et éviter déranger
tout le monde
quelques écluses en aval bertrand et son
équipage kit briard objectif loire
evènement à lécluse de baraban le public
est là nathalie aussi aujourd'hui les
éclusiers des voies navigables de france
ouvre exceptionnellement les portes du
canal
[Musique]
mesdames et mesdames danois
avec 2m majuscule à la et un noah on y
va en lève alors hop on a rejoint la
loire on a retrouvé la liberté
et donc on remonte par la loire on passe
sous fond camaléon revient à châtillon
sur loire à manteau en loire donc on a
fait un grand huit
la sterne sous le pont canal de briare
une fois encore les deux mondes se
croisent la marine de loire et les
canards